walker furniture made a special delivery  today as part of its help for heroes  campaign  this year nine families are receiving  specialized furniture  that includes things like adjustable  beds motion recliners and sofas  organizers say their goal here is to  create a better quality of life for  wounded  or active military and veterans  we're honored to be able to give back to  the vets because these are people that  have selflessly served  for our country and then sometimes they  have needs that the government just  can't help  one thing that i've noticed about vets  they're such selfless people  they don't even like to ask for help and  when they get help they'd rather share  it with somebody else  so you're really looking at a very  special breed  the event was suspended last year due to  covet 19. walker furniture has been  helping veterans though with their help  for heroes campaign for  seven years now